in the course of adapting their comic
book properties to film and TV Marvel
has made some pretty big changes to
their classic characters while some
changes have been for the best others
have risked losing the magic that made
those characters great in the first
place crack open a long box and take a
look at how these Marvel characters
should really look daredevil Netflix's
daredevil series keeps a gritty
street-level heroics instead of the
usual globe-trotting Avengers fare
so naturally producers were nervous
about undermining this realistic
approach with simple red spandex
daredevil spent most of the first season
fighting crime and cargo pants and a
black handkerchief mask all without his
famous double D's when he finally donned
a superhero like costume the comics
vivid red color scheme skewed more
maroon and most notably the traditional
skin-tight costume was ditched in favor
of reinforced leather accented in black
it's more armored than what we've seen
in the comic pages probably because
getting hit by nunchucks and swords
really hurts and by the end of the first
season
daredevil finally gets the bright idea
to wear a horn helmet instead of well
nothing let's not even touch this guy's
ridiculous first comics appearance which
pretty much proved he was totally blind
Elektra the biggest problem with
comic-book Elektra is that no
self-respecting female warrior would be
caught dead fighting and skinned tied
swimsuit in the real world and Elektra
for some reason is usually drawn covered
in so many whopping scars that she looks
like Steven Tyler's microphone stand
she's the very definition of an
impractical addressed assassin she never
even has a place to put her size give
the poor woman a holster something at
least jeans a sleeveless shirt and a
mash to hide her identity that's far
more in line with practical assassin
gear and live action Elektra wears it
well opting for the same real-world
practicality as Matt Murdock though
we'll see how crazy things can get if
Elektra somehow returns for season 3
Luke Cage he may have never adopted the
skin type getup popular with other
superheroes but Luke cages original
outfit was still pretty goofy featuring
a silver headband at a yellow blouse
open to the waist while that look
undoubtedly killed at Studio 54
it didn't outlast the 70s by 1992 it was
considered so cringe worthy that Luke
was shown tearing into pieces and the
cover of his own comic however it does
get a fun shout out in the TV series
which sees Luke grab a yellow shirt to
wear while still sporting the metallic
headpiece and cuffs from the experiment
that gave him superpowers live-action
Luke Cage for
dark clothes and hoodies which wasn't
simply an aesthetic choice star Mike
Colter told MTV News that the dark
hoodie was quote symbolic because of
Trayvon Martin we talked about that
specifically what that would mean to
people in the feelings of it evoke in
viewers what this show says politically
resonates profoundly unquote killgrave
the nemesis of Jessica Jones the purple
man is arguably one of Marvel's most
terrifying villains originally a spy
named zebediah killgrave a chemical
accident turned his skin purple and gave
him the ability to command complete
obedience in jessica jones
killgrave keeps his mind-control powers
and the suit but loses the comic book
backstory and purple skin his purple mad
nickname is never mentioned and even
kilgrave turns out to be an alias he
used to hide his sinister true identity
Kevin Tom soon without purple skin Kevin
looks like everyone else hiding his
nightmarish powers in plain sight which
is arguably much more terrifying plus
it's easier to just make him look like a
perfectly unremarkable evil British guy
who kind of looks like he's a candidate
for being the next Doctor Who The
Punisher it's kind of hard to mess up
the Punisher just dresse an angry guy in
a black t-shirt and hand him a gun
luckily Jon Bernthal not only looks the
part but does a spectacular job of
portraying a damaged soldier mentally
spiraling downward in the wake of
immense tragedy anybody at a skull shirt
and leather can pass for a decent Frank
Castle but to be able to make the
Punisher believable that's much harder
to pull off Bernthal might not always
support the iconic skull but even
without it the guy is unmistakable
the kingpin kingpins traditional purple
pants and white jacket never made it
beyond a quick reference in the first
season a daredevil probably because the
outfit is completely ridiculous
comic-book kingpins Ascot also seems to
be an upper-crust fashion realm that
didn't make it into the new millennium
in its place around Vincent d'Onofrio's
neck is nothing not even a tie instead
Wilson Fisk wears the finest suits then
again he can be wearing clown shoes
boxer shorts and a tank top and he would
still look like the kingpin there are a
few actors on earth who'd look better in
the role Netflix and Marvel must thank
their lucky stars every day for the gift
that is D'Onofrio and when one comes
across someone with such talent with
such a gift
well you don't let that go to waste
the owl leland owlsley underwent the
biggest comics to screen change of any
daredevil character in terms of
personality both are fine answers of
criminal enterprises but beyond that
they differ wildly Netflix's leland does
it bespectacled and bow-tied walking
suit comic book leland or the owl as
he's better known looks so much like
wolverine that it's not difficult to
mistake the two animal themed weirdos
older versions of the owl look a lot
more whimsical sporting a green Sherlock
Holmes like Ulster code and occasionally
he were a big ridiculous red bowtie
around his neck that made his head look
like an extravagantly wrapped Christmas
gift it's also not clear if daredevil
stuffy nerdy owl had hollow bones deadly
talons or the ability to glide but we're
guessing not fan ups the evil alien
Overlord Thanos has already made a big
impact in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
despite standing up for only about 30
seconds his love of sitting is very true
to the comics where the characters
inventively named space throne can
travel between dimensions compared to
the comics Thanos this costume has been
updated to give him a more armoured look
replacing skin tight space spandex the
blue and gold color scheme remains and
his helmet is now a separate piece
instead of being connected to the neck
plate the characters traditional purple
complexion actually did make an
appearance in the Avengers but was
replaced with a milder blue by guardians
of the galaxy maybe he just needs to
work on his space tan Loki
Tom Hiddleston's Loki has mostly stuck
close to the source material although
he's yet to match his comic equivalents
gleeful mischievousness like turning
Thor into a frog for example his costume
remains fairly faithful to the comics
and even this famous horn helmet makes a
few appearances the main change is the
same one most comic adaptations make
switching Loki's classic skin-tight cats
dip for something a little less
revealing the costume has also been
toned down a little with darker greens
and less vivid gold trimmings that said
Loki is a shapeshifter spending notable
periods of the comic as a child a woman
a magical unicorn and can even pop off
his own head when he feels like it so
it's hard to say for sure what the
character should really look like thanks
for being totally unpredictable Loki
thank you thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to watch more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to let us know what
you think about the costumes of Marvel's
on-screen heroes